.
Ist Burnout
eigentlich eine echte Krankheit?
Burnout -
oft stellt man sich das so vor:
Man arbeitet und arbeitet,
überarbeitet sich,
bis man irgendwann zusammenbricht
und gar nichts mehr geht.
Ausgebrannt,
Ende Gelände, Tschö mit ö.
Aber Burnout fängt viel früher an.
Burnout beschreibt ein breites
Spektrum an psychischen Problemen
im Zusammenhang mit Beruf und Arbeit.
Doch es gibt bisher keine eindeutige
medizinische Definition von Burnout.
Streng genommen
muss man also die Frage,
ist Burnout eine echte Krankheit,
definitionsgemäß
mit Nein beantworten.
Allerdings gibt es Burnout-Symptome,
über die sich Experten einig sind.
Dazu zählen, 1.:
extreme emotionale Erschöpfung.
Man fühlt sich
müde, ausgelaugt, überarbeitet.
2.: Distanzierung oder Entfremdung.
Man kann sich mit seiner Arbeit
nicht mehr identifizieren,
man ist gefühlstaub,
wird vielleicht zynisch.
Und 3.: Leistungsabfall, man wird
schlechter in dem was zu tun ist.
Aber wo ist die Grenze zwischen
Burnout und ganz normalem Stress?
Die Frage muss lauten:
Wo ist die Grenze
zwischen normalem Stress
und gefährlichem chronischen Stress?
Die verläuft fließend.
Als Folge von chronischem Stress
schleicht sich Burnout langsam an.
Aber für die Betroffenen kann es
durchaus plötzlich erscheinen,
wenn man sich der Symptome
nicht rechtzeitig bewusst wird.
Oder wenn man eigentlich
Spaß an seiner Arbeit hat.
Spaßige Arbeit ist zwar
zunächst gesünder für die Psyche,
verleitet allerdings
zu Überarbeitung.
Und Verpflichtungen und
Leistungsdruck bestehen ja trotzdem.
Chronischer Stress
kann viele Folgen haben.
Ich zähl' mal nur ein paar auf:
Schlafstörungen, Angstzustände,
muskuläre Beschwerden,
geschwächtes Immunsystem,
Bluthochdruck.
Langfristig steigt das Risiko
für Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen,
Übergewicht,
Depressionen und eben auch Burnout.
Wo ist die Grenze
zwischen Burnout und Depression?
Burnout bezieht sich
auf einen beruflichen Kontext,
Depression
betrifft eher alle Lebensbereiche.
Doch tatsächlich
sind typische Burnout-Symptome
ebenfalls typisch
für eine Depression.
Für viele Experten ist Burnout als
Vorstufe zur Depression zu verstehen.
Manche warnen davor,
dass hinter vielen Burnout-Diagnosen
bereits
eine Depression stecken könnte.
Vielleicht auch eine Angststörung
oder das chronische Fatigue-Syndrom,
bei dem Betroffene unter extremer,
anhaltender Erschöpfung leiden.
Burnout ist aber für manche leichter
zu akzeptieren als Depression.
Burnout klingt
nach einem Leistungsträger,
der es übertrieben hat,
Depression nach einem
schwachen Gemüt, sogar Verlierer.
Das ist nicht nur falsch,
sondern sogar gefährlich.
Diagnostiziert man Burnout voreilig,
könnte es dazu führen,
dass schwerwiegendere Probleme
nicht erkannt und behandelt werden.
Doch wer bekommt am ehesten Burnout?
Manager, Lehrer?
Können es auch Schüler bekommen?
Gibt es sowas
wie ein Mindestalter für Burnout?
Burnout
kann prinzipiell jeden treffen.
Doch die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist
bei manchen höher als bei anderen.
Frauen sind,
wie bei Depressionen auch,
öfter betroffen als Männer.
Und Menschen unter 30
sind seltener betroffen als Ältere.
Aber es kann auch Schüler
und Studierende treffen,
ja, selbst Eltern.
Da ist es ein besonders großes Tabu.
Dabei ist das Sich-Kümmern um andere
emotional besonders belastend.
Gefährdet sind daher auch
Kranken- und Altenpfleger,
Ärzte, Sozialarbeiter oder Lehrer.
Doch was ist jetzt die Ursache?
Bürde ich mir selbst den Stress auf?
Liegt es
an meinen Arbeitsbedingungen,
oder bestimmen meine Gene,
wie ich mit Stress umgehe?
Alles davon spielt eine Rolle,
und zwar gleichzeitig.
Zu den äußeren Faktoren
gehören nicht nur Arbeitsbedingungen,
sondern z.B. auch
sozialer Rückhalt im Privaten.
Zusammen mit Persönlichkeitsmerkmalen
und genetischen Faktoren
beeinflusst sich alles gegenseitig.
Wenn zwei Menschen
dieselbe Arbeit machen,
der eine gut damit klar kommt, der
andere aber einen Burnout erleidet,
hilft es nicht zu sagen:
"Reiß dich mal zusammen, dein Kollege
kommt doch auch damit klar!"
Genau wie jemand durch Passivrauchen
Lungenkrebs erleiden kann,
während jemand anderes mit 80 Jahren
noch fröhlich vor sich hin qualmt,
sind auch psychische Krankheiten
von mehreren Dingen abhängig.
Aber warum werden psychische
Beschwerden scheinbar immer häufiger?
Das fragt sich auch die Wissenschaft
und kommt zu dem Schluss:
Sie werden nicht wirklich häufiger.
Doch da immer mehr
psychische Erkrankungen erforscht,
verstanden und definiert werden,
werden sie auch
häufiger diagnostiziert.
Außerdem suchen sich Menschen
häufiger professionelle Hilfe,
während man früher das
eher mit sich selbst ausgemacht hat.
Und was kann man jetzt
gegen Burnout tun?
Wendet euch bei Bedenken an
euren Hausarzt oder eure Hausärztin.
Die können euch
an Spezialisten weiterleiten.
Und wenn es euch
seelisch nicht gut geht
und Ihr niemandem zum Reden hat,
gibt es z.B. die Telefonseelsorge.
Die ist übrigens
nicht nur übers Telefon,
sondern auch online und in
vielen Städten vor Ort für euch da.
Da Burnout noch keine
psychische Erkrankung ist,
sondern eine Warnung,
eine zu entwickeln,
können wir es auch positiv sehen
und dankbar sein für diese Warnung.
Doch was euch hilft,
seien es mehr Pausen,
eine zeitweilige Freistellung von
der Arbeit oder Achtsamkeitsübungen,
das kann bei jedem
unterschiedlich sein.
Ich kann euch an dieser Stelle
nur erzählen wie ich damit umgehe.
Bei mir kam dieses Jahr
beruflich viel erfreuliches zusammen.
MaiLab, Quarks, ich hab
mein erstes Buch geschrieben;
aber ich hab viel zu viel gearbeitet,
jedes Wochenende und sehr oft nachts.
Ich hatte keine Zeit
für Familie, Freunde, Sport.
Oft vergaß ich sogar das Essen.
Ich fragte mich, ob ich vielleicht
kurz vor einem Burnout stehe.
Aber ich hatte ja
keine Zeit, mich zu informieren.
Na, dachte ich,
ich mache einfach ein MaiLab-Video.
So kann ich Arbeit und persönliches
Anliegen verbinden, ich Fuchs.
Momentan fühle ich mich auf jeden
Fall erschöpft, sehr erschöpft sogar.
Das wär' ja dann schon Mal
ein Burnout-Symptom.
Aber zum Glück
fühle ich mich bei der Arbeit
noch weder distanziert
noch demotiviert.
Doch ich muss ja nicht warten
bis der Burnout kommt.
Ich kann ja schon vorher
Konsequenzen ziehen.
Deswegen macht MaiLab
jetzt erst Mal Winterpause.
Und wenn der Youtube-Algorithmus
angeblich sagt,
Du musst jede Woche
ein Video hochladen,
dann sage ich jetzt einfach
Fuck you, Algorithmus,
es gibt wichtigeres als dich!
Ich bin optimistisch dass ich
dieses Mal noch gesund davon komme.
Und im neuen Jahr
sehen wir uns dann wieder,
mit aufgeladenen Batterien,
und darauf freue ich mich.
Bis dahin, passt auf euch auf
und bleibt sicher!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)